TO DO HIS JOB.
>> Jesse: CHARLIE, THANKS.
THIS WHOLE ORDEAL, QUITE
HYPOCRITICAL OF APRIL RYAN, WHO
MADE A NAME FOR HERSELF AT
WHITE HOUSE PRESS BRIEFINGS,
DEMANDING ACCOUNTABILITY.
>> HAS HE THOUGHT ABOUT STEPPING
DOWN, BEFORE NOW?
>> NO, I THINK THAT IS A
RIDICULOUS QUESTION.
WERE MOVING ON.
>> IT'S NOT RIDICULOUS.
>> I LET YOU RUDELY INTERRUPTED
ME AND HER COLLEAGUE, I'M GOING
TO ASK THAT YOU ALLOW ME TO
FINISH MY ANSWER.
>> YOU CHOOSE NOT TO CALL ON ME.
>> GO AHEAD.
>> YOU ARE NOT GOING TO ANSWER
THAT?
SPEAK AND WHEN I CALL ON YOU, I
WILL BE HAPPY TO --
>> YOU ARE NOT GOING TO ANSWER
ME?
>> GO AHEAD GO AHEAD.
>> Jesse: BACK WITH ME NOW,
DAN BONGINO, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR, AND CHRIS HAHN,
FORMER CHUCK SCHUMER AID AND
HOST OF THE PODCAST.
IMAGINE IF SARAH SANDERS HAD
TREATED APRIL RYAN THE WAY APRIL
RYAN TREATED THIS GUY.
IT'S CRAZY.
>> PEOPLE WOULD BE CALLING FOR
SARAH TO BE IN HANDCUFFS, ARE
YOU KIDDING ME?
DO YOU UNDERSTAND, JESSE, HOW
EMBARRASSING THIS STORY IS?
SHE WORKS FOR A NETWORK, APRIL
RYAN, THAT HAS PROMOTED A
BASELESS CONSPIRACY THEORY
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT FOR NOW
CLOSE TO WHAT TWO AND HALF
YEARS?
LIES ABOUT THE PRESIDENT.
WHILE THAT NETWORK COMPLAINS
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT BEING AN
ENEMY OF THE PRESS, WHILE THE
SAME PRESIDENT -- JESSE, YOU'VE
BEEN WITH FOX FOR A WHILE.
HAVE YOU EVER SEEN A PRESIDENT
DO AS MANY PRESSERS AS THIS GUY?
EVERY TIME HE JUMPS ON MARINE
ONE, HE ANSWERS 200 QUESTIONS.
>> Jesse: THE MOST TRANSPARENT
PRESIDENT WE HAVE EVER HAD.
I GUESS THEY THINK HE IS TOO
TRANSPARENT.
>> WHILE THEIR EMPLOYEE A GOES
MANHANDLED A PRESS GUY FOR JUST
SETTING UP A CAMERA.
I MEAN, THE IRONY HERE IS AS
THICK AS PEA SOUP, IT'S REALLY A
BAD LOOK FOR CNN.
>> Jesse: CHRIS, JIM ACOSTA,
SOMEONE SNEEZES AND HE WRITES A
BOOK ABOUT HOW HE IS UNDER
SIEGE.
THEY HAVE SOMEONE PHYSICALLY
MANHANDLING A REPORTER WHO IS ON
THEIR OWN TEAM --
IDEOLOGICALLY -- AND THEY BURY
IT AND DON'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT
IT, PRETEND LIKE IT NEVER
HAPPENED.
>> SO, I WILL SAY -- I WILL GIVE
YOU THE POINT, IT WAS
EMBARRASSING.
I DON'T THINK REPORTERS HAVE
BEEN THROWN OUT LIKE THAT.
I DON'T KNOW THE FULL SITUATION,
IF THERE'S WAS A SITUATION --
>> Jesse: YOU HEARD HIM SAY
THERE WERE OTHER PHOTOGRAPHERS
THERE DOCUMENTING THE SPEECH.
>> I HEARD HIM SAY IT, BUT I
DON'T KNOW THE FULL STORY HERE,
AND I DON'T THINK YOU DO,
EITHER.
BUT I WILL POINT THIS OUT, THERE
IS A BIG DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
AND THE PRESS SECRETARY.
AND A REPORTER GIVING A PRIVATE
SPEECH.
YOU GUYS UNDERSTAND THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
PRESIDENT, WRIGHT, WHO IS --
>> Jesse: I UNDERSTAND THE
DIFFERENCE.
>> HOLD ON.
AND A REPORTER GIVING A SPEECH,
MIGHT HAVE BEEN A PAID SPEECH.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU KNOW ANYONE
WHO HAS GIVEN A PAID SPEECH,
THAT YOU HAVE A CONTRACT FOR WHO
CAN AND CANNOT BE THERE.
THEY ARE NOT OPEN TO THE
PRESS --
>> Jesse: IT WAS OPEN TO THE
PRESS, HE WAS THE ONLY ONE
BOOTED.
AND DOWN, I'M WONDERING WHY SHE
DIDN'T WANT THIS GUY THERE.
WHAT WAS APRIL RYAN GOING TO SAY
THAT WAS SO SECRET AND SO
PRIVATE?
>> LIKE APRIL RYAN HAS THE
NUCLEAR FOOTBALL IN THE BACK
ROOM, AND SHE WAS GOING --
>> Jesse: DOES SHE HAVE EDGY
MATERIAL SHE DOESN'T WANT TO GET
OUT THERE?
I MEAN, COME ON.
>> I JUST TOLD YOU WHY!
>> GIVE ME A BREAK, IT'S A TOTAL
JOKE.
AND CHRIS, LISTEN.
IF YOU WEREN'T IN THE POLITICAL
WORLD, I WAS IN THE
SECRET SERVICE WORLD, YOU KNOW
THEY INTERSECT.
WE HAVE BOTH DONE EVENTS, DON'T
BE NAIVE ABOUT THIS.
YOU KNOW THIS WAS HANDLED
COMPLETELY WRONG.
YOU NEVER, EVER STEAL THEIR
STUFF AND THEN ROUGHHOUSING
GUY -- I MEAN, THIS IS THE
BIGGEST ROOKIE MOVE EVER.
CNN, YOU NEED TO SERIOUSLY
REEVALUATE --
>> I CONCEDED THAT POINT.
IT WAS MISHANDLED, BUT LET ME
JUST ANSWER JESSE'S QUESTION.
WHEN PEOPLE GIVE SPEECHES FOR A
LIVING, THEY DON'T WANT IT
RECORDED BECAUSE THEY WANT TO
GIVE THE SPEECH SOMEWHERE ELSE.
>> Jesse: I USE NEW MATERIAL,
I'M NOT GOING TO RECYCLE STUFF
TO A DIFFERENT --
>> EVERY CITY, EVERY SPEECH --
>> Jesse: I ALWAYS HAVE FRESH
STUFF, I WANT TO KICK YOU OUT, I
PROMISE.
I WANT TO PLAY A SOUND BITE FROM
THE SAME KOOK THAT ACCUSED
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
OF RAISING AND LOWERING THE FLAG
ACCORDING TO NAZI NUMEROLOGY.
ROLE LATE.
>> THIS IS WHY IT IS SO
IMPORTANT TO LOOK THROUGH THE
LENS OF RADICALIZATION, WHEN YOU
LOOK AT AND APPLY A COUNTER
RADICALIZATION TECHNIQUES.
IF YOU CALL TRUMP FOLLOWERS
RACIST EN MASSE, THEY COALESCE
AROUND EACH OTHER AND BECOME
MORE DEFENSIVE.
PROTECT THE LEADER, JUST AS THEY
WOULD IN A TERRORIST
ORGANIZATION, TO COMPLAIN TO THE
RADICALIZATION PROCESS.
>> Jesse: THE MEDIA JUST
COMPARED TO TRUMP VOTERS TO
RACISTS.
>> YOU KNOW, I CAN'T BELIEVE
THIS GUY IS STILL ALLOWED ON THE
AIR.
THIS IS THE 88 NUMEROLOGY
ASTROLOGY GUY WHO FOUND IN THE
GEMINI QUADRANT, B LOWERING OF
THE WHITE HOUSE -- HOW THIS GUY
IS STILL ON THE AIR IS BIZARRE.
THE BIGGER STORY IS NOT ABOUT
FRANK -- FBI SHOULD TELL THIS
GUY TO STOP USING THEIR NAME.
IT'S REALLY A STORY ABOUT MSNBC,
WILLING TO PUT COMPLETE LUNATICS
ON THE AIR, WHO WILL SAY
ABSOLUTELY ANYTHING AT ANY TIME
AS LONG AS IT MAKES TRUMP LOOK
BAD.
>> Jesse: CHRIS, THAT'S WHAT
THIS IS ABOUT.
THEY HAVE LOST THE MOMENTUM
SINCE THE RUSSIA HOAX
EVAPORATED, RUN ON AN ENTIRELY
FAKE PREMISE, IT WAS A
CONSPIRACY THEORY.
THE RATINGS HAVE SUFFERED, SO
NOW THEY KEEP HAVING TO PUT TIN
FOIL, FLAMETHROWERS OUT THERE SO
THE AUDIENCE GETS THEIR FIX FROM
THE TRUMP DERANGEMENT SYNDROME.
>> ALL RIGHT -- LOOK.
THAT GUY IS A LITTLE KOOKY, I
WILL GIVE YOU THAT.
>> Jesse: CHRIS, YOU ARE GREAT
TONIGHT, CONCEDING EVERY POINT.
>> YOU CAN'T PAINT THE ENTIRE
MEDIA WITH A BROAD BRUSH BASED
ON ONE ANALYST.
WHAT IF EVERYONE ON FOX NEWS
PAINTED FOX NEWS BY WHAT I SAID?
GIVE ME A BREAK.
>> Jesse: I'M JUST SAYING,
TERRORIST ATTACKING INNOCENT
PEOPLE, THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
MSNBC IS DOING, THEY ARE
ATTACKING INNOCENT AMERICAN --
>> KNOCK IT OFF, COME ON.
YOU ARE DOING THE SAME THING!
>> Jesse: I'M JUST USING THEIR
WORDS AGAINST THEM.
LET'S KNOCK IT OFF, ALL RIGHT?
YOU CAN'T BE A NAZI, SEXIST,
RACIST, AND TERRORIST.